you so much for being with us now it's
good to be here thanks for huge numbers
look look it's really concerning so you
know we all heard the child cue case the
young girl in Hackney who was strip
searched in school and I was concerned
because I want relationships to be but
between children and the police to be
really strong and trusting and I want
you know children to know that police
will keep them safe and and have their
well-being at their heart so I thought
look I will call for this data from the
Metropolitan Police to make sure it was
an isolated incident well you know I'm
really shocked and sad to say it's not
so sit between 2018 and 2020
650 strip searches intrusive searches
where children are not arrested it's
stop and search then taken to a police
station or home for one in five of them
we don't even know where they were taken
because the data is poor the 2021 data
was so poor I couldn't use it and in a
quarter of those cases of 10 to 17 year
olds Bean strips searched there wasn't
even an appropriate adult that means no
mum no dad no carer that child on their
own and we know how difficult that is
for children just be clear what's the
law on on strip searching so Laura is
this an appropriate adult should be
there regardless regardless and there's
a racial disparity to this as well which
is also massively concerned absolutely
so in 218 70 of children who are strip
searches that's 10 to 17 year olds were
black boys and over the three-year
period it's over 50 percent of children
now the data speaks for itself that's
not good enough about 20 percent of
children in London are are baim our
black Black Knight minority so for this
to be so high is not good enough
massively over represented industry
researchers massive represented in stop
and search as well but that's something
else that we will not talk about right
now and you you got the data from the
Metropolitan Police concern that if you
look at the other 42 forces it will be
the same story so what I've decided to
do do is call for this data from every
police Authority in the UK but I'm not
just going to do it once I'm going to
keep looking at this data to make sure
that it improves and sharing this data
my particular Powers as children's
commissioner mean that any public body
has to give me data they hold on
children so I'm going to use that power
for this end and I want to see change
sorry isn't good enough now the Met have
made some changes they are they have
updated their guidance now at inspector
level has to sign off you know a aspect
command has to sign off these strips
right but you know and we all know
policing is difficult we know that
children might be at risk of gangs
criminal exploitation we know that
sometimes you know these things have to
happen but you know 50 of those 600
strip searches no further action was
taken that raises the question for me
about whether they were actually
proportionate and should have been
undertaken so you know I wanted to raise
awareness on this to make things better
and so what more do you want to see from
the back you said that there are some
changes have come in with an inspector
having to sign off I mean first of all
do you think that's enough does that go
far enough right it's good start um
we need clear training and guidance on
safeguarding you know just because it
should be pretty clear though that you
don't strip search your child without an
adult being present absolutely yes
absolutely so say I mean first of all
policing we are it's policing it's
difficult but a child's well-being and
safety has to be both you know taken
into account before during and after
this level of Interest as such that
needs to be absolutely embedded an
appropriate adult must be there I need
real questions answered as to whether
the use of strip search is is
proportionate I'm concerned about that I
am going to be sending this information
to baroness Casey who's reviewing the
met and the highest authorities you know
over the place to make sure that this is
looked at it needs to be better look
let's let's say it's a little bit wider
than because I I do wonder what the the
knowledge that these troop searches
happen because these kids must probably
know someone who has been strip
searching this way without an adult or
present what does that do to those young
men who are then going out in their
daily lives and having to deal with this
sort of thing and the relationship
between them and the police absolutely
men and girls I mean five percent at
least work at were girls
um and of course there's the upset the
anger the ongoing sort of mistrust I a
children's commissioner want to make
sure there are trusted positive
relationships between children and the
police children tell me they want to be
kept safe they need to be kept safe you
know there's going to have to be a lot
of change here to make that happen but
we must commit to trying to make it
happen otherwise these things are going
to Fester as a parent can you imagine
how you would feel if it was your child
can you just imagine so this must
improve and I'm not going to stop until
it does sure you will not damage to
Caesar thank you very much